And so inshallah starting tomorrow
inshallah will be at 12:40
will be at 8:15
starting tomorrow inshallah.
Not too much.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Tonight in
we just heard in the second
also known as
how long has it been since anyone here
has heard
recited in salah usually except in
Ramadan when we are finishing the Quran.
on probably never or next to never,
right? Everyone is scared of the saga at
the very end. What do I do with it? Do I
make sjud and then come back up? Do I
not make sujud at all? Should I make
sjud and then add another surah with
it? You know what? Just leave it. And so
we don't hear it that often.
is an incredibly important and pivotal
chapter of the Quran.
As we know, most of us have heard and
know that this was the first chapter of
the Quran to be revealed to the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam. Not just the first
chapter,
but the first five verses of it.
And the story of that we will hear in a
in a few minutes inshallah.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam first
received the opening five verses of
surah al
the remaining parts of this chapter from
the fifth verse all the way until its
end. It is clear that it was revealed
way later.
Why? Because at the very end, Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala speaks about the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam's
antagonists
and the chieftains in Mecca and their
harm of the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam and their rebellion against him
and their antagonism of him and his
followers. And this only happened in the
subsequent years after his da became
public and began to change the
landscape of society at that time. when
he started to get followers, when he
started to have a very big effect, this
is when they started to rebel and fight
against him. And their antagonism first
started as mockery and later turned
violent and oppressive and tyrannical
which inshallah we will get to. This
chapter at its end speaks about that.
But its very beginning, those first five
verses,
those were the first verses of the Quran
to be revealed to the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam
in of any part of the Quran. These were
the first words that he heard from
Gabriel
when he came to him in the in the cave
in
and he brought to him these five words.
As a matter of fact, Gabriel didn't say
anything to him other than these five
verses.
And in order to understand that and in
order to understand the chapter of
we have to really look at why it was
revealed, how it was revealed, the
method that it was revealed in. Because
when we just read the book, the Quran as
it is just that, it has meanings
that all of us understand that all of us
can clearly see. But we miss the details
and the nuances of context, of climate,
of mood, of attitude, of environment. We
miss all of these things. Where do we
get these things? These details come
with scholarship.
These details come with knowledge.
That's what knowledge is. It's not just
seeing the most obvious meanings of
the Quran. It is about the nuances. It
is about the details.
He reported a narration
and this is actually the second
narration
or third based on how it is counted
narration that Albkari narrates in his
he actually began his with this
narration. Why? Because Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala began the Quran with this
verse. These verses also this narration
is collected by Muslim. Both of them on
the authority of
now when did the prophet Sam
marry?
When this happened
okay when when the prophet sallallah.aii
alaihi wasallam passed away
in the most generous of estimates was 18
years old.
When he passed away
in the most generous of estimates was 18
years old. That means that when this
happened to the prophet Samisha
was not even born yet.
However, the narration
of this, all of the chains of narration
go back to
Aisha wasn't there. The only woman that
was with him at the time
was
that was his only wife at the time. He
was 40 years old. And the timing of this
revelation
is roughly
the month of August, the year 610
after
AD, what they say AD in Gregarian.
They say after death, after
was raised and so
was not there, but it's okay. We don't
need to have her spell it out for us.
The prophet told me sallallah.aii
wasallam she was his wife. Obviously she
heard this detailed description and
story of the first revelation from the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam directly.
Almkar
mentions this narration of and she
details to us very beautifully
the experience our prophet had in that
cave on that fateful night.
None of us here probably every single
one of us has already heard this story
right? But this is the issue with
stories that we hear from the Quran,
from the Sunnah. We'll just take a
moment before we mention this to to say
this.
How many of us here have never heard the
story of Adam and we've all heard it,
right? The story of Noah, the story of
L, the story of Misam,
of Isa, of of
Har and Ibraim. Most of us have grown up
with these stories.
But again, most of us
have not heard these stories since we
grew up. And that's what's very
interesting about the stories of the
Quran.
is that every time you read the Quran,
it is as it is the poet says, "No
same man crosses the same river twice.
The man is not the same man as he was
before and the river is not the same
river as it was before." Two different
things. And so Allah tells the prophet
sallallahu alaih
remind them for indeed
the reminder is beneficial to the
believer. Often times we skip over these
things. We we I already know that story.
Let's get into the the stuff the obscure
stuff that no one's ever heard of
before. The really shocking things that
we've never heard. What we need is to
concentrate on these stories, the
stories of the Quran, the stories of the
Sunnah of the prophet sallall.aii wasam.
And we need to hear them over and over
and we need to re-examine them at every
junction in our lives because we need to
hear them and they will provide us with
guidance at each junction in a new way.
We heard these stories most of us as
children
when we thought children and we saw
the world as children see the world.
When is the last time we heard these
stories as adults with adult minds as
adults see the world? There's a very
different view. is a very different
light.
says
in her narration in Bkari Muslim
relating the story of these verses
these opening verses of
she said
[Silence]
She said
that the first beginning
stages that ushered in the arrival of
Giri
in the cave of on that fateful tonight
was that as a as a preface to this
revelation,
the prophet sallallah.aii was began to
receive revelation in the form of
visions that he would have in his sleep.
She mentions that this continued in some
narrations for six months. six months
that whenever he would see something
happen in his
sleep, whenever he would see an
occurrence, someone speaking to him,
whatever it is, he would then wake up
and it would occur exactly
as he saw it in his sleep. We're not
speaking about a mild feeling of deja
vu, as they say. I feel I've seen
this before. I feel I've heard this
before. We're speaking about reality is
occurring to him twice
every day or each time he has this. This
notes when his heart was awakened as a
prophet.
Why? What is the leading description of
the prophets and messengers
about their sleep?
When the Jews of Medina came to test
him, they said, "What is the they asked
him three questions? One of the three
questions they said, what is the
description of the messengers with
regards to their hearts and sleep?"
Anyone know the answer to this?
Speak loud. Let's hear your nice voice.
your nice muratan in voice.
[Arabic recitation]
specifically this
messenger Muhammad sallall.aii wasallam
his descriptions in the previous books
was that his eyes sleep but his heart
does not sleep.
Listen to that description. His eyes
sleep
but his heart does not sleep.
Sallallah.aii wasallam. Allah described
as coming with the Quran to what part of
the prophet's body?
He said that comes with the Quran and
revelation to your heart. That's the
that's the part that receives the
revelation first is the heart of the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam.
Prophets and messengers are slaves to
Allah
and they are and Allah is not on their
time. He'll wait for them to wake up
before he reveals something to them. The
messengergers's heart must be ready for
the receiving of the message of Allah
whenever the king of kings dictates that
this message is to come whether he is
awake or sleeping sallaiam.
And this is why you read narrations
where he would sleep and then he'd wake
up and go lead salah. He sleep through
the night. He'd wake up and go lead fud
asb said. How is he leading salah
without wudoo? His heart
is awake. His heart is awake but his
eyes are asleep. He knows whether he
broke his wudoo or not. The narrations
that state that he got up and led salah.
This means that he was through his
through the night he did not break his
his woo. So for instance when we fall
asleep this invalidates our wudoo
correct. Why does it invalidate our
wudoo? Is sleep itself what invalidates
your woodoo or the uncertainty of having
broken your wudoo?
It's the second one. Correct. That's why
the companions if they slept a light
sleep
they would wake up and pray. Why?
because they didn't have to make their
woo over because their sleep was light
enough that they would have felt if they
passed you know wind or passed broke
wind this is referred to as slumber a
light sleep right and so the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam he didn't
have this issue his heart was always
awake and wudoo is a spiritual
purification
that affects the heart in ways that we
cannot see. And so he would wake up and
make why? Because his heart was always
awake. And so
we see here that these first six months
when he started to anything that he
would see in his sleep was valid was a
premonition
was a prophecy of something that will
occur in the future. This is only from
Allah. And this articulates the time
when his heart was awakened by Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. He has now had his
heart awaken. That's why said
she said that the first receiving of
revelation that he had was
premonitions in his sleep. The righteous
premonition. What is a righteous
premonition? that whenever he would see
something occur in his sleep, when he
would wake up, it would play out exactly
as he he saw it in his sleep. Aa
described it. She says
that when he would wake up, that thing
that he saw in his sleep would occur as
clearly as the break of dawn.
meaning that it wasn't we have in
our sleep when we're dreaming, we see
all kinds of weird stuff and things that
don't matter and a mess and a tangled
web of all kinds of thoughts. And these
aren't this is not what prophets see.
Anything a prophet sees in his sleep is
considered to be what? Revelation.
That's why Ibraim he didn't say Allah
told me to slaughter you to his son is
because that in itself sounds as if
Allah is commanding something evil. He
didn't say that Allah told me to kill
you. He didn't say that. He said,
he said, "My son, I see I saw in my
sleep that I was slaughtering you." What
did is understand from this? He said,
"Yeah,
do what you have been commanded."
So he considered this as what? a command
from Allah because prophets don't see
silliness in their sleeps. Once their
heart is awakened with revelation, that
heart belongs entirely to Allah.
Sleeping or awake. That is how
revelation works. And so Aisha tells us
that the first thing he received was his
heart was awakened with the premonitions
of glimpses into the future from Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. Not that he knew
the future. He didn't know the future.
He was given prophecies by Allah of the
future which is the most prominent
description of revelation.
And that's why it's referred as
prophecy. And that is why he is called a
prophet because the most prominent
you know the most prominent
description or aspect of prophethood is
glimpses into the future whenever Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala wishes to show him.
So this if we go this we're
going to be talking about this narration
for another 3 weeks but ya what are you
going to do we got to hear it. So we
will end with that for tonight inshallah
we'll continue this in our next
sitting in our next gathering.
We ask Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
[Arabic recitation]